well the simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future it's as though
our thoughts
go out into the universe and are
accepted
and brought back to us as experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought
and every time you speak a word you are
literally
painting your future making your dinner
whatever you want to call it you are
creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start
deliberately creating what you want in
your life
and you begin to be aware of what you
don't want in your life and how you are
contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do
to begin to train yourself to be aware
of what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes
to begin with you start by doing what we
call
doing affirmations and that is making
positive statements about your life that
are positive and you do them
deliberately
you might do them in the morning you
might do them at noon you might do them
at night
you might do them you know twice a day
or whatever
but you do this and you let this become
a habit
and as you start to do them things will
begin to change maybe on a very small
level i call it getting the green lights
and the parking places
i mean they're not huge things in your
life but can be very nice when you get
three green lights in a row
and you're in a hurry doing an
affirmation is either writing it down
writing it on the wall or the mirror or
just saying it
what i like people to do is to stand in
front of a mirror
and do their affirmations because
there's something very powerful about
looking in your own eyes and accepting
yourself
or noticing that you reject yourself
when you're saying something positive
about yourself
so that would be a very beginning way to
start
say in the morning you get up in the
morning you go to the mirror
and this is a big one and it's hard for
lots of people
but you look in the mirror and i say and
say i love you
i really really love you
and to begin with that can be so hard
for people because they think of all the
things that they think are wrong with
them
but if you can start your day saying
that it's very powerful
remember i'd like to think the universe
is listening to everything you say
and everything you think and saying okay
you can get that
so then it starts to bring you in and
bring things into you
and i know this sounds far-fetched but
it's amazing how it works
you if you do a good general positive
statement for
yourself the universe will figure out
how to manifest that
how to bring that about in your life so
things could happen that you wouldn't
expect
at all but they will happen
if you think of doing your positive
affirmations
is like planting a seed in the ground
it's not necessarily true at the moment
but it is something you want to have
be true so you put the seed in
and you you you plant a seed and you
expect it to grow
or you maybe plant three seeds just in
case you expect them to grow
and you don't wait two days and then dig
in the earth and say what's happening
what's happening
you expect that thing to grow because
you know there's a law and a process
and the seed will grow if it is in the
right soil
and it has the right amount of moisture
making it really a habit
and doing it every day doing something
every morning when you wake up that's a
really good time
and another good time is when you go to
sleep at night and gratitude
works a lot if just being grateful
for everything i always say the universe
loves gratitude the more you're grateful
for what the good is in your life the
more good you get to be grateful about
and it's it's like you know if somebody
gives you a present or gives me a
present and i say oh my god
i hate that color and it doesn't fit and
you know
that person will never give me another
present
but if you say oh it's wonderful and
thank you i really adore it it's great
that person is probably going to want to
buy you a present every time they see
something they think you would like
and it's like that with the universe the
universe loves
gratitude if you have very strong
beliefs within you
that you don't deserve good things in
your life
and a lot of people have that then there
can be delays
and sometimes people say well
affirmations don't work i've done
them but when they're doing for instance
prosperity affirmations
and they've done some prosperity
affirmations and they say it doesn't
work nothing's happening and i say well
all right
how many prosperity affirmations did you
do in a day
and they'll say three probably and they
say all right how many
poverty affirmations did you do this day
and that could be 300 depending on where
you're coming from
and what are is running through your
mind
see i have this one of my thoughts about
life
is that only good lies before me and
i've been saying this for
many years so it doesn't really matter
to me
what happens in life because i know it's
going to be good
happy people praise so here's some
things i want to start doing today right
now that will
build your self-esteem super fast the
number one thing
is to praise yourself there is nothing
nothing nothing that will build your
self-esteem like praise but your praises
if you have
a shoppers and so you look really great
in the outfit yeah it suits you you must
buy it
they have an agenda if your boss says
you're amazing at your job but
i need to give you work to do over the
weekend they have an agenda
someone dating you might have an agenda
and your mind knows that
when you say i'm great at my job i'm
smart i'm kind i'm nice people like me
there is no agenda unfortunately when
you go i'm
rubbish at my job i'm boring i always
mess up and i have no friends
your mind lets that into because your
mind doesn't really care if what you say
is right or wrong
good or bad healthy or unhealthy let me
prove that to you
i want you to put your hand in front of
your face like that i want you to close
your eyes i want you to imagine
you have a big fat juicy lemon and i
want you to
breathe in that wonderful lemon smell
and just squeeze it a bit and feel that
wonderful lemon texture because nothing
quite smells like a lemon so still
really believing you have half a lemon
in your hand
open your mouth shove that lemon in
there
cram that half a lemon into your mouth
and start chewing
and sucking and biting and swallowing
the flesh keep
sucking all that lemon flesh into your
mouth bite it
chew it suck out the juice
and you will notice what is happening is
your body is responding to a thought as
if it's
a fact your body is responding to the
image and thought of eating a lemon as
if you are actually eating
a lemon and it's making a saliva because
thoughts are things
and every thought you have has a
physical reaction in your body and an
emotional response to when you think
i don't have friends i can't talk to
people
i can't take things back to a store i
can't ask for special treatment
i don't know how to talk to people then
your mind accepts that as a fact just
like the lemon but when you say
oh i can talk to anyone i'm an
interesting person i'm warm and friendly
people like me and
i can make eye contact i'm good at my
job i can ask someone out on a date
i can tell the person i'm involved with
what i need
your mind accepts that too and someone
recently said they keep a lemon on their
desk now and look at it every day i'm
sure they change it every month
because that lemon reminds them every
day that they
are responsible for what they think and
feeling in your responsibility that word
means an ability
to respond so i want you to start to
praise yourself i want you to wake up in
the morning the first thing you go is i
like myself
if you want to know how oprah winfrey
starts her day every day check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there close your eyes
for a moment will you please
and breathe with me just close your eyes
and if you will